welcome to this video playing
international master pollutes can yeah
and teammate of mine let's see what we
get play the trusted english defence
this is going for cooking night h3y I
don't turn don't know know the exact
ideas behind this okay how the night f2
III this kind of setup on light em to
where do you fall okay try to to stay
flexible what about how do I develop
this piece on be aid d6 always runs into
night f4 butcher is probably probably
not great the c5 films and probably c5
and knight c6 maybe this is the way to
go if he plays d5 d5a thought maybe a
maybe e5 okay let's just continue to
develop
and maybe I can get some some pressure
but take if i take it I do I have any
discover to text not really I won the
night age faith this may be a Muslim
not sure let's just continue to
coordinate I'm not sure maybe I could
have played night h5 but maybe even a
simple at form this a good response hmm
hmm not sure come on let's let's speed
up here try to play a form if it goes d
5 i'm not sure maybe maybe really 95 and
then have fun yeah this is this is a bit
of a problem I maybe need to to do
something else night d 8 ball maybe but
maybe maybe I can do that to have seven
months not it's not so clear that this
is a bad position or for the night I
mean d 8 is a bad position but if you
can improve they don't have seven this
isn't the problem or at least it's not a
serious issue is some still focusing on
completing a development not a bad
policy I mean just getting all pieces
into play okay if I go eat 5 he would
probably play d6 just just a quick
improving move okey aid yeah it looks so
it looks attractive for white and it's a
little bit better for wine but it's not
done it's not clear to me how how white
should improve mmm I'm wondering about
96 also maybe 96 Andy five can be in
adium
case may be preparing to key may I have
this check okay maybe preparing to play
for what I have Bishop default check
okay this I didn't expect okay let's
let's stop a4 a5 for the time being
interesting immediately playing against
the blockade on let's let's take and
play if I have closed up the position I
didn't want maybe it was it was better
to take on db5 first and then play five
I feared d6 then but this probably just
opens up Maya repa shell okay so we have
a very close position the only weird
thing is that got the Queen 96
let's consider I can play neither for
Jesus Christ right at four then you find
that maybe I can play night XD form
completely unnecessary to allow that all
stop doing that ok the question is what
about d6s the symbols that that's
helping or not ok I need to I need to
make sure that I'm the one playing on
the King side first so age 51 age for I
can just take now get the the rook to a
change ok the king is tried to escape I
should I should really try to play the
six it's hard to do without now of
course it's obviously very close but I'm
the one to to try something on g4 and ok
it's playing on this trick on g 5y I i
ah ok
you know I didn't intend that
so what No
I know this looks a bit weird do I don't
see how you can punish it
grah our third ok now let's fight let's
fight time morning I probably should
take the draw yeah I should clean edge
aight mate oops Queenie jade was check
mate check go quickly to to come check
check check I only have Jeff seconds
this is not much check check check check
mate oh wow this was more than lucky the
head yet the ultimate the Ottoman move
Queen h8 checkmate at one point here
with 20 seconds on the clock acta took
here and check Nate this is a [ __ ] yeah
this is an improvement before that i'm
pretty happy pretty good shape but yeah
okay I of course I overlooked age form
and I should I should not allow that
maybe look H 7 Mary instead of that
it's it's not clear that I can win
anyway it's of course nice with the good
push up against this terrible piece but
the only real chance are sacrifices on
fon g4 and it's not clear that I can
actually manage to to play that it's so
it's difficult and at the end of Cade
was just a matter of notice it's not a
very quick guy with the mouse is much
faster on and then real over the bow
chess but with the mouse it's a bit
tricky all right it's an interesting
game anyway thanks for watching